this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living and being well
i'm george campbell your host joined
today by rachel cruz best-selling author
and host of the rachel cruz show we are
here for you america taking your calls
the number is triple eight eight two
825-5225 that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five azia kicks us off
in maryland
azaya welcome to the ramsay show how you
doing
hi thank you so much
what's going on so yeah i'm so excited
thank you i love it i love the
excitement i'm glad you called
yeah thank you and yeah i have a
so the first thing is the english is my
second language please bear with me and
then i'll try to be cooked
you're very patient you're doing great
thank you so yeah i came here for a
study and i learned english and i
finished my mba
and
made it and stayed here
so yeah where are you from originally
i'm from mongolia mongolia
wonderful
yeah
yes so how can we help you
yeah so before the marriage of course
you know i bought the car i was going to
test my car you know when i leave
i was going to take my car to my country
but you know however i stayed here and
then since i listened to the show i paid
off my car two and a half years early
awesome and right yes and i paid off my
uh no right now i have my title and i
wanted to put my husband's name and but
he's a little bit aware you know
so
that's how you know you can talk about
the finance and then also he wants me to
um
get another credit card
so you know to keep you know my score
and something oh so your husband
you guys disagree on how to handle the
finances he wants you to get a credit
card
is that the big issue right now
yes you know of course you know we
wanted to buy a
house in like 2-3 years
yes so yeah now right now we have um
so we have you know he's uh
dead we have his student loan and his
car and 401 so
what's the total debt that you have
around like
68 maybe okay
and is that mostly student loans
no like
like 33
okay
when i talk with him you know like how
much do you have or like you know and
he's a little bit aware and he doesn't
want to talk so he just shuts down
do you know why he doesn't want to talk
about the money
well you know he
he said you know he used to work in the
bank the collection
so you know he knows you know how they
works or something so
now he wants you know my credit score is
good you know but i don't use it i just
have it but my husband you know wants
you know keep you know yeah so i think
one of the scorers yeah so one of the
big kind of flags that i feel like i'm
hearing so
you know we can go on the tactical money
piece all day long and george can even
chime into that too but um you know you
can buy a house without a credit score
you can do manual underwriting like
there's ways around all of this but the
biggest thing that i'm hearing
from you is that you're trying to do one
thing with your money and your husband's
doing the opposite and it's going to be
really difficult for you guys to win
long term
um with your money and i think
ultimately how much that starts to seep
into your marriage because when you're
not on the same page about anything big
in life i mean this could be raising
kids this could be about in-laws this
could be about money
there starts to become that wedge and so
one of the big things i would really
really encourage you to do is to figure
out okay
how can we get on the same page how can
i approach him
in such a way that i'm not
you know nagging or badgering but i
really am telling him hey as your wife
here's what i've seen here's kind of
what i've learned
um and i kind of and i want to walk this
path with you because i want to build
wealth and i want to win with money and
this is what i've realized is the
fastest way to do that
and
and see how he responds and the and the
issue is though if he responds like well
sorry i still want to do my thing
at that point that's more of a marriage
issue um
is what ends up happening where you guys
can't you know play on the same team and
that's really what you what you guys
want to get to
yeah he's saying like you know he used
to work like the bank and you know he's
from here
he's am i cancer
so and then yeah he's saying you know i
don't you know understand understand the
systems or you know so he's trying to
say well i get it and you don't so you
should listen to me
well anna baker is going to have a very
different philosophy than we have at
ramsey so
so it is i mean you honestly these
principles that you're learning
is going to go very counter against
everything that he knows in his head
logically as a banker um and so it that
it may be a difficult sell but i think
that it's more than just hey i want to
do this with money it's just hey i want
to be on the same team
um and work with you and share with them
you know here's how i feel i don't feel
safe i don't want to have more debt in
our life it's going to add more anxiety
and stress to our marriage i want us to
have a great marriage here's my vision
for what our future could look like
here's how i want us to get there
are you on board and that could be a
different conversation when it's coming
from a place of here's what i'm excited
about for the future and this is going
to get us there the best safest way that
could change his mind and another thing
i'll give to you is financial peace
university i think if you guys watch the
nine lessons in financial peace
university it will give you guys a
shared language to talk about money
he'll understand where you're coming
from mentally when you go this is why i
want to become debt free this is why i
want to buy a house this way it'll
change the way you guys communicate so
can i give that to you as our gift
yes thank you so much awesome yeah so
hang on the line austin will pick up it
also comes with every dollar premium
and if you get do you guys do a budget
currently
i'm trying to numb the sellers you know
he's the spender so
uh so he's the spender so he wants does
he want more control over where the
money's going or do you have a say in
the matter
well we talked you know now we have you
know
almost you know he's dead and then but
i'm trying to telling explaining the uh
baby steps and then but he said you know
i can't you know work more than what
he's doing right now so
i couldn't talk with him you know in my
language
yeah that's how i can explain how long
have you guys been married
and now like year and a half now a year
and a half okay so yeah this is uh still
fairly new we're still getting you know
there's communication barrier there's
the financial um kind of component there
so but i don't want to hit i'm so sorry
no go for it well and i and i want you
to have the confidence you say that that
what you are leaning towards on how to
handle your money
it's the right way and i know that
people think that we're so black and
white here but i'm like over 30 years
it's been proven that when you don't
have debt you have your income you can
invest it you can give it you can save
it for a down payment you can buy a home
without a credit score we don't have to
live in the cycle of this culture that
everyone else lives in you don't have to
and so don't let him undermine you just
because he's a banker just because
you're not from america and you're not
speaking english is not your first
language it doesn't matter the
principles regardless of where you're
from or what language you speak are
still the same principles so be
confident be kind and respectful
but i would i would push into this
suzanne it might be more of a marriage
issue okay so remember that hang on the
line we're going to get you one year
ramsay plus which includes the financial
piece university videos and every dollar
premium hope it's helpful on this
journey thank you so much for the call
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by
rachel cruz this is the ramsey show give
us a call triple eight eight two five
five two two five we wanna help you take
the right next step in your financial
journey jose joins us up next in salt
lake city jose welcome to the show
hello guys how are you just happy to be
here awesome what's going on with you
excellent i'm just happy that i'm in the
english a second language uh sema hey
this is
i love it i love this
how can we help um
yeah so my question is goes through um
about my mortgage so
uh personally my wife and i managed to
be in data steps four five and six
awesome we already completed for a step
four so we are investing 15 percent and
we are working towards in january
start putting away money for our kids
college and our mortgage so our plan is
to start putting a thousand dollars
towards a mortgage
and i did an amortization table with my
mortgage company and they
said that it was going to be somewhere
around 15 years to get rid of the
mortgage
and then i also put a thousand dollars
in a investment calculator and it says
that investing in a much mutual fund for
uh ten percent
uh in ten years i should be able to
catch up and just pay a lump sum on
whatever is left on my motor so i wanted
to know your opinion on which route
should i go
i love it well it's a great question and
it's it's one we do get you're saying
should i am i better off investing that
money instead of putting it towards the
house
it's going to the house
in one point i just was but it's going
to take me five years shorter if i
invest the money so i just put in
directly the investment calculator is um
it's hoping
there's no guarantee that you're going
to get you know the 10
rate of return every year that
amortization schedule if you put a
thousand dollars on that mortgage it
will go away at that point and so one is
kind of aspirational could happen
uh the other one is guaranteed and it
reduces your risk and it reduces the
interest that you're paying
and so i like the idea of paying off
your mortgage faster while investing 15
percent a lot of people think well
ramsay that you should be investing that
money listen i was investing the whole
time we were paying extra on the
mortgage we're gonna be just fine but
now without a mortgage payment we can
invest way more what's your mortgage
payment jose
uh
it's about 1600. boom
so i like the idea of you guys really
attacking this mortgage freeing up that
sixteen hundred dollars that can then
really set you up for success long term
yep what do you think rachel yeah well i
mean i and i see the math that you're
doing jose but also what george said
you're not calculating risk because what
if you were supposed to pay off your
mortgage in 2022
from what you and you were able to pull
the money and you're like oh the
market's down i've lost so much oh my
gosh so so the point there is that yes
mathematically i understand where you're
going but also mathematically think if
i'm putting extra on the principle of
the mortgage
then i'm gonna be paying less and less
like what you're saying on interest
which will help you even right get it
paid off even faster and
to jose when it comes to money again
people go straight to the math which i
understand why but but there's also
other elements here
when it comes to money so there's a
emotional element and seeing your
mortgage
continue to tick down and tick down and
tick down and knowing that it's going to
be absolutely paid off and watching that
process and going through that process
there is something emotional there that
an investing calculator is not going to
give you
and we say right here that personal
finance is 80 behavior it's only 20 head
knowledge and you're going at this more
like 80 head knowledge and a little bit
of behavior so i kind of want you to
even flip the script to say okay
what if mathematically it's still wise
to throw money at the mortgage because
again your principal's going to be going
down um
and your mortgage is gonna be going down
but
uh but also there's something where you
see the light at the end of the tunnel
and you know i'm gonna have no payments
and what george said too when you don't
have a mortgage you can throw all of
that
uh towards investing as well
but uh are you sold jose
i'm alive yet yeah definitely definitely
do it i've been listening for you guys
for four years so i kind of knew that
that was going to be the answer but i
just wanted to hear the reasoning behind
absolutely call us when you're dead free
and tell us if you regret it how's that
that probably won't happen oh come on
jose come on man have some hope you got
this buddy here's the other thing rachel
that people don't really talk about when
it comes to this piece there's a forced
savings plan when you put that money
into your house and people think well
the money's there it's in the equity of
the house when you sell it you have that
money the problem with investing it is
you're doing it and it's a taxable
account yeah this is not retirement
investing so you're going to pay taxes
on it and when you see a pile of money
you go man we could really do some home
renovations could use an upgrade on the
car that's a vacation right there
there's no guarantee you're going to put
that towards the house yeah because life
happens yep exactly when you have that
pile of money yes you might be second
guessing what you're going to do with it
even though you've had it stocked away
for reason and people do that
idea even with purchasing something
right like you're saving up i've heard
so many people say this saving up for
like a really great car or whatever it
is and they're like i have a huge amount
of money i don't want to spend it all on
a car and i'm going to choose a
different one so it is amazing what
happened so keeping that plan in place
and just yes throwing it at the mortgage
and not
really depending on the market in there
that's the growth there is oh yeah
all right elizabeth joins us up next in
san francisco elizabeth welcome to the
show
hello thank you for taking my call
absolutely um
i think so i have a rental property
and
we have a home as well
and a bunch of debt and
some pensions and 401ks could i spend
but the reason i'm calling you today is
because i'm trying to figure out
what order to do all of this in and i'm
familiar with the baby steps but i'm
just a little bit overwhelmed
and i got an estimated preceding
proceeds for the
what we're going to get for the condo
um for 168
845. can i throw some members at you yes
absolutely yep okay great
so we have a 401k loan from 9 300. we've
got credit cards um totally 16 000.
we have a another 401k loan for
29 800.
in a bank loan for 25
800.
um that all totaled around 81 000 total
and then we had 200 000
open equity line with the current
balance of 27 000.
and um
we have my husband is an electrician
do you want what he grosses or what he
meant because someone that goes into
pension and different things you can
give us the net
okay so he met
2
800 a week
and
sorry we have a
68 000
pension plan um which is like his little
401k and the two hundred thousand dollar
pension plan
200 230 000 pensions i mean yeah you
said you're selling the this is the
condo your rental you're selling it yeah
we're selling it i mean i have big
feelings about that but
you're doing it to get out of debt yeah
we're doing it
um in all honesty we're doing it because
my husband makes a lot of money but for
the last um three weeks he was
out of work and it made us realize
how
we are on thin ice yeah and we really do
need to clean up yes and he's fine
everything is fine
with the proceeds of the condo how much
debt could you knock out
oh and we owe my father-in-law 150 000
but he is not in a hurry to get back oh
my goodness but um
yeah all right
hey okay so elizabeth if you were to
sell the condo tomorrow how much cash
would you have from it
168 000 would that knock out all of your
debt other than the father your the
father person alone
um
okay well that's going to be my game
plan oh i would sell that tomorrow
elizabeth i would sell that tomorrow pay
off everything those 401k those were
gonna go first
uh irs and 401k you want those out first
you don't have irs yet but the 401k and
then start attacking that yeah pay off
that credit card pay off that bank loan
don't get rid of the heloc no no more
and you've got to stop playing and
change change your habits change your
habits this is going to be like a little
wand over all of this which is amazing
and a gift
but stop doing what you guys were doing
to get yourself in this mess you guys
got this this sounds stressful and i'm
not even involved and i lost my breath
you got it though you got it you can do
this this condo sale is your united
shining armor so use it to your
advantage get rid of debt never look
back no more helocs no more personal
loans borrowing money from family
yikes and then we're focusing on paying
dad back oh boy this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined by rachel cruz we
are here for you america and in the
lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage kenneth and lois are
with us from fremont california how are
you guys we are well thank you you made
the trip all the way from the bay area
to be with us today yes yes thank you
for having us what a journey
uh so tell us about this how much have
you paid off
so we paid off
hundred
246
fifty two dollars choreographed look at
that look at that two hundred and forty
six thousand wow okay how long did this
take it took us
25 months yes
okay wow what was your range of income
during that time so we netted 140 to 160
000 and our gross was about 180 to 220
and came back down to 200. wow
what do you guys do for a living
i'm a teacher
yes and i'm a nurse i'm a clinical nurse
specialist and i also train nurses um i
precept
advanced practice nursing students wow
wonderful where are you guys from
originally from
kenya kenya wonderful actually i kind of
knew that we spoke right before the
world because i had her teach me some
cool kenyan phrases
because i was so excited do you remember
them of course moments ago
wow what a story it's amazing you guys
the numbers here are jarring this is a
wild so what kind of debt was the 246
a car loans
everything so credit cards uh student
loans
we had
family loans friends loans we were just
you are getting money from whoever will
give it to you yes oh my goodness
so how long have you been in america now
this is the 15th year
yeah so did you get here and you were
like
let's do this welcome to america let's
get some debt
yes they told us this free money they
give you cards and you can just swipe is
that real they said here's a card it's
free money have fun that's what it feels
like a credit card yeah yeah and you
feel like this is this is the best place
ever okay so what happened 25 months ago
to start this journey yeah so i'll start
um
it started five years ago we were
building a house for my mother in africa
and we were not using any budget we
were just
spending using credit cards from any
store that they gave us
and we were using our money to build and
also to help other people that needed
help
and then three years ago we moved up a
house where we live is very expensive
so the apartment cost was going up 200
so 250 dollars every year we decided we
are done with the apartment we are going
to a house and the house was four
thousand dollars a month
and the apartment was
eight hundred so we thought we made the
right decision to go to a three bedroom
house at that time by the way four
thousand dollars where we live is just a
small three
three bedroom apartment uh house
so then um we a friend would come by and
say something about ramsay we don't know
what thing that was
but
we said okay
something like that okay then two years
ago a friend invited us to fpu class
that was being done at the near nearby
school church school
and i went with her i did not know i was
going to meet that ramsay there
so the first class
and then the second class did me and wow
i went and told my husband you have to
come to this
and
he was not coming he was reluctant to
his story
so at first i was not interested i was
not interested and then eventually i
decided to to join her to these meetings
so when i watched those videos i was so
interested and then we made up our minds
uh to make a decision we had separate
accounts before so we decided to have
joint accounts wow
yeah we were borrowing from each other
actually um when he's broke he asked me
to give him some money and when i'm
broke i'm asking him if another bill is
coming wow
the other thing we wanted to say is that
we they told us we need to build our
credit
so when we started we had like 750
credit
when we ended up with 10 credit cards in
fact there were 12 you know two more
from every store sometimes we'd forget
to pay one bill or another and our
credit started going down so we ended up
with 669
and
that was the end of it when we did fpu
we thought oh
so it's okay not to have credit cards
and student loans that we were paying
just minimum we decided we will
just
go all the way you guys are amazing what
a trend you are amazing coming here 15
years ago and making an incredible
income and sure not knowing right you
kind of just fall into the american way
because what you just described is so
normal so normal that is how a majority
of people do life with their money
and you made a decision where you're
like oh i'm done so what was what were
you guys feeling kind of before because
you're the one that went to the class
originally right so so were you were you
not happy with where you guys were
financially were you stressed or were
you kind of like oh i'm okay i'm gonna
just still go with my friends
what was what were kind of your emotions
leading into it
um i'll start since it's me with that
yeah um
we were very stressed out um
we were not talking about money apart
from when we were trying to borrow from
each other
and we are saying no we are not going to
do this
and we would pray together
and trust that
god will do something it will be okay
but we didn't know what to do well we
were just
living horrible like that
paycheck to paycheck
so
this was a blessing that my friend kathy
invited me to fpu
and my eyes were open so give it to my
husband
yeah so it was a lot of stress it's a
lot of stress we could not
make it we could not be able to provide
for all that we
wanted but now we we have a a relief and
uh just a peace of mind yeah you're
amazing and your shirts tell the story
set free yeah yeah sit free by choice we
were in bondage
wow yeah the borrower slave to the
lender you guys figured that out oh so
yeah so how does it feel now standing on
the stage with all that paid off a sense
of relief
and it's a dream come true
we feel like this whole rock from on our
back is taken away
our marriage is better now we can talk
about money openly and you're not just
bank accounts to each other yeah you're
way more than that you're partners
that's right so how did you do this
cause i'm looking at the numbers i'm
going today paid off 123ish a year
making 141 how'd you do this did you
sell something yes so what we decided we
we decided to downsize because we were
living in a very expensive house so we
decided to downside and go to uh an
apartment one bedroom so ah a little one
bedroom apartment correct and with how
many people
four of us so four of you our children
have a story to tell but um they were
very willing to help us with this
they actually decided to go to africa
for a while so we can save this huge
private school bill that we were paying
here wow and there's a life hack send
your kids to africa for school to save
some money yeah that works that is a
huge sacrifice though
for how long was that they did it for
six months they came back in january of
this year wow yeah amazing well can you
bring them up on the stage and tell them
uh tell us their names and ages yes so
isaac
is 13 and sarah is 12. wow isaac and 13.
you all did this together as a family
literally yeah you all cool you all made
decisions together as a family to do
this incredible absolutely incredible
tell us what is the key to getting out
of debt
um
yeah i'll say one is to stay focused
and to give tithe was very important for
us yeah giving to god and then budget
yeah and to have to have discipline and
tonight to deny yourself and work hard
beautiful i love it well speaking of
generosity we've got some things for you
a copy of baby steps millionaires dave's
number one best-selling book that's your
next chapter a copy of the total money
makeover you can give to someone else to
kick-start their journey and one year of
ramsay plus including all the financial
peace university lessons that changed
your life every dollar premium you can
pass that on or you can go through it as
a family to keep you inspired on the
journey you guys ready to do this yes
okay it's kenneth and lois and isaac and
sarah from fremont california
246
552 dollars paid off in 25 months making
180 to 220 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two
[Applause]
[Music]
my face hurts you're smiling so hard
they're just a beautiful joyous family
everyone out there that's like i can't
do it i can't do it listen to them shut
up listen you can do it that's that's
amazing oh incredible set free that is
the theme of this hour and you can be
free to america you can do this you just
gotta follow a plan commit to it this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ramsey
personality george campbell joined today
by rachel cruz we're taking your calls
triple eight eight two five
five two two five
all right rachel so i've been following
uh some news but not the kind you think
i like to follow sports news because you
know i'm known for my sports knowledge i
already talked about like inflation and
the recession that's hard news no this
is different these are two of your
favorite things sports and money
this has been the hot artist
this is from cbs news lebron james
no i know you ready for this lebron
james is officially a billionaire really
37 years old okay can i can we do a
quick timeout just so i can so all of us
that are like me listening can get our
minds around this it's not just from
playing basketballs this isn't this is
endorsements oh yeah there's all kinds
of deal sponsorships you name it just
make sure not just his nba salary
eight-time nba all-star four-time nba
champ two-time olympic gold medalist hit
another milestone
doing something no other nba player has
ever done wow after another monster year
of earnings totaling 121.2 million
before taxes and agents fees over the
last 12 months forbes estimates he's
officially become a billionaire while
still playing hoops 37 year old
superstar is a net worth of 1 billion
and he said this is a quote from him
it's my biggest milestone
obviously i want to maximize my business
and he's done just that he's commanded
more than a 385 million salary from the
cavaliers miami heat and lakers and uh
as the nba's highest-paid active player
and off the court to your point rachel
he's raked in upwards of 900 million in
income from endorsements and other
business ventures so he's a very smart
businessman totally on top of being an
incredible jordan yes very similar
so here's the funny thing though this
isn't just why i wanted to talk about
this
yes he's a billionaire that's an amazing
milestone and that's a thousand millions
for those of you that need to get that
picture in your head
so
but my favorite thing about this story
is that he is known as the cheapest
player in the nba he's extremely frugal
i want to play a quick clip that our
team found to really illustrate the
point you ready i'm ready i can't wait
who is the cheapest guy in the nba who
is it and dwyane wade says
lebron james that is so
so so so fast
that is so falsely true it is so falsely
true and using his phone if it ain't
wi-fi i'm not turning on data raw man
i'm not i'm not buying no apps
i still got pandora with commercials
i'm not paying for it i'm not paying
i love so that was lebron james himself
for those of you wondering talking about
how cheap he is and i love that he said
it's so so falsely true that's so true
he won't he i love that he needs wi-fi
he's not gonna go now let's be clear
lebron james is not living in a check
he's got nice house and i'm sure he's
got nice cars he's done really well but
it's amazing to me the things that he
goes i'm not paying three bucks for that
i'm not doing that i'm not paying for
that subscription pandora i'll have some
commercials yes hey do you know who else
is not a billionaire but listens to
pandora with commercials
rachel cruz me
that's me
we were sitting and i was like rachel
what are you doing playing pandora
like do you not have spotify who are you
basically just i'm basically like lebron
that just means you're on your way to
becoming a buddy and no apps either no
here's that no like paying for apps yeah
yes i want to make it clear lebron james
is not a cheapskate in fact he's very
very generous
and that's the there's a maybe a
connection there maybe you can speak to
this uh he this another article from cbs
news lebron says he'll open a
multi-million dollar medical facility in
his ohio hometown he's built the i
promise school in his hometown of ohio
he's sending 20 he's pledged to send 2
300 students to college debt-free
through scholarships
amazing so to me i just go this guy has
a plan for his money he's got a vision
for where he wants it to go and while he
doesn't care about the three dollar
pandora subscription
he's spending his money where he wants
to spend it and i respect that
absolutely yeah because it's not the
pandora thing you know the pandora
subscription is going to make you a
billionaire right that's not that is not
it but it's a mindset too
of seeing like okay what's wasteful
what's not and it's that's the same ways
of looking at life
that really could lead you because i
mean that i mean that kind of stuff
could play into his business deals where
he's like um where are we what am i
doing right like it's that same thought
process that really can make you become
successful i mean it's wisdom it's just
wisdom with money and where where your
values lie lebron has to find wi-fi i
know i well here's the thing right now
can i be honest with you
i waited 20 years for space jam 2 and i
was so disappointed
with how it turned out
and that's partially lebron's fault but
i've gained newfound respect for him
after this
this whole thing oh man lebron so he
wrote he ruined the space jam franchise
but he brought it back do you know what
is so weird and i'm not kidding i don't
know what what this is what's happening
right now but you know we do a movie
night with our kids on most friday
nights we do 90s movies so dunstan
checks in dennis the menace
uh blank check richie rich like we go
through all the 90s movies because we're
like because you gotta you gotta watch
these
uh jumanji was a little scary at the
trailer so we decided not to munchie but
do you literally you know what we're
watching tonight space jam yes the
original the oh yeah oh yeah yeah
michael jordan michael jordan like with
looney like looney tunes one of my
favorite movies because my kids don't
know looney tunes like like bugs bunny
she's like millie was like oh is that
the guy that eats the carrot besides the
wb logo and i was like yeah cause free
willy he's on for you know it's
hilarious so like all of this is
happening tonight train up a child in
the way they should go rachel there you
go michael jordan space jam so lebron
i'm happy for you i might pop by the
cruise house just to like be a part of
this moment eric can we keep going with
this topic or is this better okay okay
so
here's another 90s movie that i quoted
on the road when we had our building
wealth event
there was a samsonite
suitcase and i made a comment about
samsonite ha ha can't you know i made a
joke about it george had no idea what i
was talking about he was like i don't
get it i was like well yeah from the
from the movie and he was like what
movie i was like dumb and dumber george
said
never seen it and i said what i said
that is my husband's favorite movie fast
forward two weeks
ago uh winston i haven't done i don't
know what's being talked about
he quotes dumb dumber as he does like
every week it's just like the movie
quote always in our marriage and i said
do you know george has not seen dumb and
dumber once and said george campbell's
not seen dumb and dumber next thing i
know george campbell is driving to our
house when sarah's
rents or i don't know we actually use
your hbo max subscription that's right
and we say and we
george me and winston we watched dumb
and dumber it was a night listen when
you get a text from winston cruz that's
like hey come over tonight we're
watching dumb and dumber you can't say
no to that you clear your schedule
you move mountains
whitney was out of town we wanted to
come to be clear so 90s movies yep it's
uh it's an important thing that you need
to dive into so all you gen zers out
there that i haven't seen those nine
times to be clear i'm not gen z i just
had a strange childhood i guess i guess
so i grew up arabic baptist we were
watching like veggie tales adventures in
odyssey we weren't allowed to watch that
kind of filth really you know at the
ramsey household that is one thing mom
and dad were not strict parents on they
were strict in some way you could watch
them we could watch what literally would
everyone except for two movies can you
say them on air i can or two two things
rugrats we were never allowed to watch
foreign
because the kids are in charge
so he would always say so dave didn't
like that it portrayed in a world where
the kids kids yes he hated that and then
fern gully
hold on couldn't watch foreign is it
because of the climate change agenda i
don't know i'm not gonna go down that
fast that is hilarious
but dave's like it's capitalism they're
cutting it down to make paper rachel
that's how the world works get over it
so in the 90s rugrats and fern golly we
are not but everything else forest gump
titan anything
we watched y'all like
yeah and mom and dad didn't care this is
great content listen if you came here
you may not care about anything
financial advice and life change you
came to the wrong place sorry for the
segment i'm sorry there's no time to
move on the show's over rachel you can't
take a call quit oh no we can't take a
call quick hey but we can circle back if
you were a billionaire what were things
that you would you would still
who how would you be lebron how would
you i would still i would still coupon
and i know sharon ramsey kindred spirits
sharon ramsey because we both are big
fans of in being intentional is this the
best deal is there a deal to be had can
i use a coupon a promo code whatever it
is i'm doing it it's good regardless of
how much regardless of how much money
you have someone made fun of me because
of how frugal i was it's like george you
haven't paid for how why are you and i
was like you're never too rich to have
to get a great deal that's how i feel
that's a great line
i'm glad we're ending with that and i'm
not rich but i mean by american standard
sure by the world standards from a net
worth saying george you paid for your
house thank you rachel well listen we're
on our way to becoming billionaires with
our teaching already thanks lebron thank
you following in your footsteps good job
lebron we're proud of you man way to go
what a milestone as if we're friends
like he's gonna text me later anyways
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books which many of you are thankful
for we'll be back with you before you
know it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host host of the
fine print and entree leadership podcast
joined today by host of the rachel cruz
show you guessed it it's rachel cruz
herself and we are here for you america
to help you take that right next step
maybe we're at a crossroads you need
some confirmation you need a third party
to give you some encouragement we are
here for you the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five nathan kicks us off in kansas city
nathan welcome to the ramsay show
thank you how's it going today how can
we help
pretty good how are you um
i need some advice about i'm on baby
step two and if i could
reduce my gazelle intensity
right now i'm working 60 hours and at
two jobs 20 hours at one
and there's the opportunity to stop that
20 hours or at least reduce it
uh right now i would be comfortable with
keeping the main job and just losing
those 20 hours
but my debt would
uh
age would extend a good year too
so how much debt do you have
i have 54 000 right now
um working to babysit i was at 65
earlier cool what kind of day
uh car and student loan mostly a little
bit of medical okay
and what's your income household
uh
with
my main job 72 a year and with my uh
side job
2400 a month
okay
and is is your wife working outside the
home
that's
a lot of questions i'm losing a lot of
time with my kid
how old are your kids nathan
he is two
yeah okay so if you're doing the math
from what you said if i cut my
20 hour a week position it's going to
keep us in debt another year or two
um
how long would you how long until you
were out of debt if you kept the 60
hours a week
i could be out of the debt entirely by
2024
um that's with the assumption that it's
just gonna end eventually
um my main focus right now is taking
care of my car payment i can take care
of that by september once i take care of
the year concern it goes away
okay so you're saying two years is the
current track with the extra job and if
you lose that 28 000 a year that you're
doing with the side job it'll extend it
by another year or two
yes how much is the car loan
uh right now it's 12. okay okay okay
what's the car worth
8k
um
well it's kind of one of these things
nathan i mean you know it's
the the math is there meaning
you know how much it's going to be
how much you're going to have to work
how much you're going to have to make um
to get out of debt and this time period
versus two years and so
it's really a values question for you
and your wife to sit down and say hey
what do we value right now
in this season
um
to
you know to knock out this debt and we
talked to some people that are on one
end of the spectrum and they're like we
will scorch earth we will do nothing
but work and pay this debt off to get
out to get out as quickly as possible to
get out faster so that we are oh we
could just let our foot off the gas and
then enjoy life versus dragging it on
another year or two but then there's
people and it takes them four years you
know to pay off this debt like what
you're kind of what your track would
more be
if you if you did not pay that off so so
honestly i can't answer
the question of like what you should and
shouldn't do um i mean we talk about
being gazelle intense and really
doing what you can to pay it off
obviously if there's
you know issues at home or there's um
you know
you know mentally if something's if
something's wrong you know like we want
you to take care of yourself as a whole
person
first and foremost i mean that's
important um but also i do think that
we've gotten comfortable
in our
i don't know i feel like a little bit in
this time of life of like um
you know that man i i don't want to
i don't know it's not that i don't want
to miss out
but also like i i don't want to
sacrifice
the family time yeah to do this other
goal which again is there's not i don't
think like necessarily a right or wrong
in it but i think you know if you look
back i feel like i could be totally
wrong like 10 or even you know 20 years
ago
um it was more accepted
to work longer hours i don't know is
that fair to say i think that's fair i'm
just looking at the numbers going man
right now you're pulling in a hundred
thousand
with this side job and when you lose
that you're gonna lose steam you're
gonna get comfortable and now it's just
gonna be plugging away for four years it
just feels like a really long time to
make any level of sacrifice so if i'm
you i'm sticking it out i'm going to
find some way to still have that family
time maybe the side jobs at a different
time so they're not asleep when you get
home but i'm going to figure out a way
to keep this level of intensity income
wise without sacrificing too much family
time but at two i mean now rachel you
can speak to this as a mother being away
from your little kids for you know oh
yeah a lot of times that's that's hard
yeah oh absolutely yeah i mean but it's
not gonna ruin their childhood either so
there's this balance of like they're
gonna be okay
yes yes and and i think too you know you
read so much in that parenting space and
it's like that quality versus quantity
you know i mean there's so many ways to
go about parenting right so so again
nathan i i hate to like not give you an
answer on this call but i do think it's
a values question for you and your wife
to sit down and say hey
what do we want to do um as a family but
i don't think your two-year-old is going
to be scarred
uh in life you know i think about my i
mean when dave was doing this i'm like
he was he was doing he was teaching at
finance peace university live
every night
uh gone almost every weekend doing
events and we went sometimes we didn't i
mean like it was a whole thing for oh
for a long time i mean the amount of
hours you know he put in and and i look
back and i'm like and i didn't feel i
don't feel which again everyone's story
is different but i didn't feel like
abandoned i didn't feel like i didn't
get time because he was at the important
things and when he was home we were home
and we didn't have presents and we
didn't have cell phones attached to us
like we do now there's so many
distractions now where
then i feel like you were able to like
really get time so and i don't remember
the early years like i don't remember
when i was two when he was doing all
this they were coming out of bankruptcy
when i was born so so i just want to
give you a little hope nathan that like
your dad heart might be broken of like
man i'm not there for my two-year-old as
much as i want to be your wife might be
exhausted no not might be she is she's
exhausted she's the one doing bath time
and bedtime and she's the one doing it
all it's exhausting
but it's one of those things to say okay
is it worth the sacrifice uh to get out
yeah and i think that level of sacrifice
makes you go never again yeah never
again are we gonna put ourselves in that
kind of position and i'm gonna be here
for my kids because of the sacrament is
it more of what you're feeling nathan or
your wife
uh i'm a single dad so i'm feeling like
oh i'm so sorry my goodness so what a
child we just totally assumed i
apologize no that's okay uh i won't know
so i get to be there for him and like
the sense of i'm being him i'm print a
bit but there's not that interplay
there's not that quality time it's a lot
there but it's not quality
well that feels like a solvable issue of
how how can we be more intentional with
the time that we do have because you are
working from home
but man if i'm in your shoes i'm keeping
the intensity up because i want to i
want to sacrifice for as short of a term
as possible even if it's intense
so that's my plan but again it's a
values question and we're rooting for
you either way
thank you so much for the call this is
the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
imagine the energy of a jam-packed arena
filled with people ready to experience
what it means to live life to the
fullest now picture all of your favorite
speakers together on one stage
empowering you with tools and principles
that will create unstoppable momentum in
your life that is smart conference you
heard it right folks smart conference is
back it's been three years since we've
done this event and we're pumped to get
it back on the road in dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd now this isn't
just another pep talk this is thousands
of people just like you coming together
under one roof to learn how to build
wealth achieve their goals strengthen
their relationships and so much more and
we have a good time this might be the
most entertaining event we do
there's usually live music there's
theatrics ken coleman's doing backflips
who knows what you'll experience
and uh all of our personalities will be
there rachel will be there i'll be there
dave ramsey john dolone you name it the
whole gang plus special guest craig and
amy grishall from life church will be
there as well talking about marriage and
event passes start at 39 for an all-day
event we're talking eight to five
so get your passes before they sell out
because this event definitely will
ramsey solutions dot com slash events is
the place to be rachel is there a better
event than smart conference i'm just not
sure
so fun well you get every part of your
life
you know talked about whether it's you
know it's marriage it's parenting it's
money it's
uh goal-setting it's your career i mean
like literally every part of your life
we talk about and we have a lot of fun
it's a really fun of it it's like the
ramsay buffet you get a little bit of
everything a little bit of everything
you know and you will leave stuffed
mentally
and probably physically we you know
there's there's food there too so join
us ramsay solutions.com events can't
wait
kevin joins us up next he's in houston
texas kevin welcome to the ramsey show
thank you for taking my call happy to
take it what's going on
so in about eight months i expect a big
jump in my career god willing so we
weren't really looking to get into a
house or make a purchase on the house
until then but recently a family friend
offered to sell their house and it'll be
below market value and i guess like an
owner finance deal if that's what it's
called i just wanted to call and ask is
the discount i guess you'd say worth the
risk you know until my income would go
up and we could you know afford it then
and if not what would make this deal
worth pursuing
it's great questions kevin so give me um
some numbers what what do you guys make
a year
sure uh me my wife with single income uh
currently with no overtime or anything
just about 2100 a month and you know in
that eight-month period i guess
is that your take-home pay about like
sixty percent oh yes that wasn't that
take-home pay okay
and do you guys have any debt right now
no we're debt-free completely debt-free
do you all have money in the bank just
for a down payment or emergency fund
yeah so we have 30 000 saved up and then
recently the company i worked for sold
but it was employee owned and so
i didn't have to contribute anything but
the shares i got just for working there
um were 76 000 and you know that was a
big blessing
and that went into an ira and you know i
could take 10 000 i believe without the
discount for a house but you know
yeah no okay so the 30 grand though you
have liquid so that's all the all the
liquid cash you have to your name that's
non-retirement
correct but part of that's your
emergency fund
yes okay and how much how much is the
house
the the house is 2 30 um and just going
off houses in the neighborhood like it
hasn't been
officially appraised i guess but just
right across the street probably around
they're going for like 300 000. okay and
do you know what the mortgage would be
on a 15 year
uh 15 year i think if like uh around 12
or 1300
okay
it feels real high for your current
income what's it what's it going to go
up to in eight months and how
for sure is that is that a guarantee
uh so i work in trades i'm an apprentice
right now um and then once i get my
license that'll be it'll go up by you
know at least 60 just on the pay then
there's a lot of other incentives where
uh you know just like the numbers we've
been running it you know we should be
right at the uh like um
you know having the house cost like a
quarter of our take-home pay
on a 15-year
yes okay
i don't know kevin how soon do you have
to do this deal
soon um i guess this summer like
probably by july or august they would
like a decision or else we'll just put
it on the market yeah
um
you know it's for me
i think you have enough for down payment
at this point cause you have your
emergency fund but outside of that
you've got you know about 10 grand to
your name for the down payment
right
which that's not much on a 230 000 house
that's not even 10
right right
i know kevin i hate to say it but i'm
like if this was two years later i think
it would be great and if you guys liked
it but i would i would have i would not
keep them on the mortgage like it so you
need to do a whole clean up there if
that's what you guys did
in two years from now we're talking
about today
and for me i just have to say kevin the
numbers aren't aren't there for me right
now for something like a house
um
and with the gamble of like in eight
months and i'm sure
your income will go where where you want
it to but still
um
it's not there now it's not a guarantee
now and so that makes me that makes me
nervous
yeah i mean just
crunching the numbers i'm just worried
you guys won't be able to eat
even for the next seven months if you do
this deal
because what i'm seeing exactly with ten
thousand down that's four percent and
your mortgage would be
uh two thousand dollars and you told me
you take home 2100
correct
so i
so if i could add it would be zero down
i don't know for like owner finance if
they would require pmi i know you know
zero down's not like the best but if so
it's the worst thing you have no equity
i don't want you to have foreclosed on
this house because two months in you
have regrets that it was a terrible
decision
you know a deal on a product person when
i can't afford it is not a deal
and so i love that your friends doing
this and i think in other circumstances
it could work out and kevin let me say
this too when there's situations like
what you're in right now
it feel it you get tunnel visions so
quickly because you look and see
oh it's it's the only deal
it's a great deal it's with through my
friend oh i have to take this because it
feels like there's no other options
you know that this is going to be the
best thing and we have to do we have to
we have to do it because and you start
to live in this tunnel and i want you to
kind of bust through that tunnel and say
okay
what if instead
we got you know money saved up i started
my new career and we look up 12 months
from now
and see where we're at with our with our
cash flow and
go and buy a house that you know there's
tons of houses out there and granted the
housing market is freaking all over the
place we know it's insane right now but
um
and then and then say okay what are my
options then because this this is not
the only deal in the entire world and it
feels like that because of all the
circumstances that you're laying out for
us so i know it can feel on your end
like oh this is it this is it this is it
we got to take it it's the best deal you
have no idea what a year from now is
going to bring
when you actually do it where the math
plays in and you're actually being smart
about it on that end versus rushing into
something because it feels like a good
deal does that make sense
it does no it i mean
the the market being so crazy sometimes
it does feel like the you know kind of
the only deal on the market and
originally told them you know we're
we're still renting right now but uh
yeah no it is just attractive i guess
but uh yeah would they let you rent it
from them sure that's a good question no
that was our kind of like uh we thought
about it for just like a few days and we
came back to them and say we do we'd
rent it
but they're retired and they said it'd
be too involved and so
they were just just think about it for
you know a few months and come back to
us yeah we just wanted to yeah
and on their end they're probably like
okay we're gonna sell this
we're retired we're good we could offer
it you know a great price to this couple
that we love
you know like that like it all makes
sense and it's very kind of them but i
just don't think you guys are in the
position to do it today i would not
kevin personally i just look at the
numbers and go i can't ever thinking
about 90 of my take-home pay going
towards the mortgage
and then not being able to put food on
the table because we wanted to be
homeowners for six months
right and so i just i i love you too
much to put you in that kind of position
and you know a few years down the line i
don't think you're gonna have this kind
of fomo because you're gonna buy a house
when it's the right time for you yeah um
and not look at this deal with a lot of
regret you're gonna go man i'm glad we
passed that up we dodged a bullet yep i
really do i think so so i'd pause kevin
how old are you kevin
28 28. well i'm pulling for you you're
going to be a homeowner soon enough with
your diligence and you know set up a
different savings account for that down
payment and maybe you save up 50 grand
75 grand in the next couple years your
income goes up now you've got a healthy
down payment to put down you can afford
the mortgage payment now that's a deal
right there that gives you some peace
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by rachel
cruz ashley is up next in dallas texas
and ashley i see on our screen that you
are debt free
hi yes i am we love to hear that tell us
about amazing how much have you paid off
i paid off 111
000
in 18 months wow oh my gosh what was
your range of income during that time
um i started at 75 000 jumped pretty
immediately to 120 000 and last year i
made 160 whoa
ashley what do you do for a living
um well i was travel nursing ah there we
go that would do it
well you're incredible you've been
busting it that's amazing i was busting
in yet so tell us about the hundred
eleven thousand how much of that was
student loans
majority um probably ninety six thousand
yeah and what was that
the rest was um a little bit of credit
cards a car
a tiny bit of medical expenses
wow you're incredible so
tell us what got you on the path 18
months ago to go no more i'm not living
like this
um well i had just graduated from grad
school and had a hard time finding a job
and getting things going with the
pandemic
a friend reached out and asked me if i
wanted to start travel nursing
and it just seemed like a good
opportunity to get on board with that um
there were
um i actually finished my nurse
practitioner degree so
um kind of delayed with that a bit and
just decided to go ahead and pay my
loans off
so wow
that's incredible so how'd you find out
about ramsay what was the thing that we
went all right i'll follow this baby
step things debt snowball thing
well i've been a listener for a long
time several years but once i graduated
from
grad school i really sat down with the
numbers
and knew that i needed to do the dave
ramsey plan which is what i knew i was
going to do since i started school
so originally i was doing the math it
was going to take 30 about 36 months um
but once i started started traveling and
cut it in half yeah you doubled your
income and you went okay well that just
cut our timeline down didn't it how old
are you ashley
um i'm 31. okay so for most people i
feel like when you graduate and you're
making you know this kind of money which
obviously you're working extremely hard
doing it but you're making 160 a year
are you married
i'm not i'm single i won't be continuing
to make that much i was working a lot of
overtime sure sure to get out of debt
yeah
but i just said
yeah i was going to ask though like you
know when you're
you know late 20s early 30s and you're
making this kind of money it would be so
easy to be like oh
i'm gonna go on a great vacation
i'm gonna do whatever i want because i
feel like i just have so much so what
kept you motivated to say no this money
is going to this debt i'm not allowing
these numbers these dollar signs of
making great money
uh you know take you off track
um well i listened to the show almost
every day and i would just listen to
people like sharing their why and that
became
my why was the biggest thing was as i
just shared i've
been single and i just always wanted to
go into a marriage
debt-free and be able to start a family
debt-free without any financial burden
well you're so cool you killed it 111
thousand dollars in 18 months that's
amazing we'll add this to the dating
profile this is amazing
yeah that's incredible so what was the
biggest sacrifice you made along the way
something you had to pass up give up
sell
obviously worked overtime which that's a
big sacrifice on its own
yes and just being away from my support
system
i turned down a couple of a nurse
practitioner jobs along the way
um so that i could just really focus on
paying off the debt um but i just took a
position i'll be making 115k salary
which was more than those other jobs had
offered me wow and i'm debt-free so yeah
that's right well i'm curious do you
feel like it makes you a better nurse
practitioner to be debt-free
um definitely i think i can go into my
job and my mind is clear and i have
taken a little break now and i just feel
more prepared to walk into that career
that's amazing yeah people don't think
about the head space and brain calories
and you know it's living in your head
rent-free yeah sally may's up there
going you owe me some money at the end
of this month remember that that's right
did anyone think you were just crazy for
doing this
i did have some people along the way
especially those in the same career um
saying you know you putting it off is is
gonna put you behind a bit but now i'm
here i am 18 months and i get to walk
into it so that's amazing was it worth
it all the sacrifice all the overtime
it was it was worth it i feel free so
talk to the the other nurse who's
sitting there with a hundred eleven
thousand dollars in debt who thinks it
can't be done i'm gonna wait for someone
to fix all all of this debt what do you
tell them the key to getting out of debt
is
um
[Music]
like i said for me it was my why you
have to really decide why why do you
want
to be debt-free and just have a circle
of people that are supporting you
along the way cheering you on and just
sticking to the plan
well we're so proud of you you're an
inspiration to so many out there
especially the amazing nurses all over
the country who have you know been
through hell the last 18 months yes
thank you for your work thank you so
much for doing that we've got a copy of
the baby steps millionaire book for you
that's your next chapter as you continue
to build wealth and look to the future
we also have a copy of the total money
makeover maybe you can pass that on to
one of the nurses you work with to tell
them that it can be done and there is
hope out there and also a ramsay plus
membership which includes financial
peace university every dollar premium to
help you along the way or you can gift
that to someone as well you ready to do
this thing
i'm been ready yes boom it's ashley from
dallas texas a hundred and eleven
thousand 000 paid off in 18 months
making 75 all the way up to 160 with
overtime as a travel nurse count it down
ashley let's hear a debt free scream
three two
one i'm debt free
[Applause]
that's impressive too
she's busting it that's one of the
benefits of being single is like well i
don't have to be home
i'll just keep working just keep working
every time being exhausted being
exhausted but man that's amazing amazing
well rachel what do you do when you come
across something that helps you do life
better you tell your friends right sure
that's what ashley's gonna do now that
she's debt-free yeah absolutely and when
you find a great new gadget a reliable
mechanic a new restaurant you know you
love to recommend it you don't want your
friends to miss out on a good thing and
that's partially why the ramsay show has
grown to be one of the biggest business
and finance shows in the world uh
millions like you america tune in and
you can't help it but share it with
friends you gotta listen to this ramsay
show stuff because it's changed their
life it's changed their family tree they
share how they've cut up their credit
cards they've gotten out of debt for
good like ashley how they've saved and
built wealth way beyond what they could
have ever imagined
it's strengthened marriages and
relationships we love to hear how this
stuff has restored marriages yeah
they've gone on the same page how people
have reached their career and life goals
by becoming debt free and the stuff ken
coleman teaches so whether you found us
on podcasts youtube or your local radio
station don't keep it to yourself don't
hide it under a bushel all right share
your favorite episodes of the ramsay
show with your friends and family so
they can get the hope and help they need
because no one should miss out on this
good thing and we know your favorites
are you know with me and jewelry tell
them hey just skip the ones where rachel
and george aren't on that's fine i know
just go to rachel george's that's what
people want
but it is fun we love to hear how that
yes that's what gets you to change your
life you're not it's not a you know
sometimes it's a paid ad on social media
but a lot of times it's a friend saying
oh i'm listening to this new podcast you
gotta check it out it's called the
ramsay show give it a shot yep
absolutely and we get so many calls on
hey how do i talk to my parents about
this stuff how do i talk to my friends
about money because i don't like
struggling
yes and it's like this is the this is
we're like the third party to come in
and help like the third party usually
is the best just to say hey here's
here's this over here
that has really helped and i love it
it's entertaining it's fun to listen to
and i learn a lot
and that's it i mean it's a way to
really get your friends and family on
board as well yes so thank you to all of
you who have shared the show and helped
us make it what it is consistently
number one on apple podcast and business
uh number two radio show in the country
and we can't do it without you folks and
the good news is we got more of this
show coming right up we'll be back with
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back with more of the ramsey show
i'm george campbell joined today by
rachel cruz and it's your show america
so give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five melissa joins us
up next in saint charles missouri
melissa welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call i
appreciate it absolutely how can rachel
and i help
we're hoping you can help my husband and
i and our son make a very tough decision
that needs to be made very quickly oh
okay we yeah
stakes are high
my husband and i uh bought a car for our
son in 2019 it was a 2018 kia soul for
about 14 000 plus taxes
and registration
during that time we had
to
put a new engine in there so we've
invested probably another 6 000 in that
car in the last couple years
last year he was in a car accident
it was deemed his fault so he put a
claim through our insurance they fixed
it
but then in this march when it renewed
they dropped him
so we had to go through a broker to get
a new insurance um and it was at about
twice the premium of what he was paying
but
we we had to do it so
you have to have insurance
so now he's got this new insurance since
march and then the unthinkable happens
monday night his car is stolen oh my god
now we're in a very worse condition
because the argument between my husband
and i is do we put it clean through
because we know what's going to happen
when that renewal happens next year
they're going to drop us and then the
insurance is going to go his premium is
going to go even higher
and we talked to our broker and he
pretty much confirmed it yeah it's going
to go up um he doesn't know how much
could be as high as 800 a month he just
he doesn't know for sure so
the tough decision we're trying to
decide is do we
do the put the claim through and risk
our son being straddled strapped with a
high premium for years until it drops
off he said it could take up the five
years
for the drop off or do we bite the
bullet kiss that money goodbye for the
on that car
and
pull money out of our savings
and help our son get another used car
how much how much would you have been
able to get for it like how how is it at
20. we believe around 12 000. okay and
he's got 2 000 deductibles so
we'll be walking away with maybe 10 to
put towards another car
what are the unknown factors what the
premium is going to be
down the line for sure what are you
paying now for the insurance
he's paying almost 300 monthly okay 21
so he's at the high risk so he's already
paying high to begin with
well i'm just gonna do the math and go
okay let's say you know have you talked
to an outside you know third party
insurance agent to get an estimate on
what this could be yes this is the same
broker that got us his insurance just
this march we called him and he said he
could add 800 a month potentially or
just up to 800 could be
it could be because he now he's got to
go out and find someone else that's
going to insure him with a second claim
yeah and he said it could be it could be
as high as 800 a month he doesn't know
well if it's 800 a month absolutely it's
not worth it because that's 10 000 a
year
yeah that you're now paying to file that
claim to get 10 one time but that's
worst case scenario that's worst case
right so that's where i'm going
is there a way to figure it out without
running the claim i don't know that
there is without actually running your
insurance yeah
he said he could start doing some
research for us but i mean he would have
no way to know exactly what that amount
is he's just given us the worst case
so i don't know my husband feels like so
we invested so much money in it that's
why you pay premiums we need to put the
claims through we need to get recoup
some of our loss i said yeah but as a
parent do i want to strap this our son
with this huge pre possible how did the
car get stolen melissa where where was
it stolen
in a parking lot in a parking lot it got
stolen they just like hot wired it and
took off or was the key in there
uh the key wasn't in there i guess they
somehow got in there and got it going
and you can't find it i mean
it find it police report and all that
reports yeah we did the police report
and unfortunately the police is not
responding we've been calling for days
to get an update because
we've never had this happen before so we
checked online they said oh wait about
five days sometimes it shows up yeah we
can't get the police to call us back to
get any update so we're gonna assume
it's it's gone it's at a chop shop it's
gone and we gotta make decisions because
he's got a job it's already become
inconvenient trying to get him to and
from work sure so that's why i say it
needs to be quickly how old is he
he's 21. and does he have any money
saved
um not much a little under 3 000 saved
he doesn't have a job that's like the
career job right now he's still working
at it he's just not there yet and do you
guys have money to basically gift him a
car right now
we do but uh my husband's a little
irritated because we've already done
that once yeah and there's a part two
melissa he's 21 you know
like yeah it's tough he's got it he's
kind of gotta get some skin in the game
here yeah i would once well he was
paying us back he paid us back for the
motor he was paying us back uh half of
what the car cost so he was putting get
you know he was contributing yeah um but
it's just horrible timing he wasn't done
paying his half of the car and
it's just we're just all just not sure
what to do here and i thought well let's
call the guys that know about money what
makes sense yeah it's hard to do when
the numbers are so variable because
usually we just look at the math and go
is this going to roi does this make
sense to do from a mathematical
standpoint but there's too many unknowns
here to say for sure do this now if i'm
in your shoes
i might just save up and get them a
cheap used car
instead of that's exactly what the
broker said he said
i i asked i said what would you do if it
was your son he said i would just get a
cheap car and we're not going to get him
a 14 000 car we're going to get him a
four thousand dollar car
you know and i thought that too and i
started looking and then i realized i
remember dave ramsey said about oh it's
covered and these car prices are through
the roof and oh my gosh they are i
couldn't find anything
under 10 that didn't where are you
looking like over 100 000 miles well
it's so i don't care if it has 160 000
miles find them an old toyota or honda i
don't care if it's a 1999 those things
will go forever and melissa and he needs
to be looking too like i'm hearing you
as the mom which i'm i get but also he's
21. he's 21. like he needs to this is
his this is his problem you know what i
mean like you guys obviously are there
supporting him but i'm involved in every
step of the process i want him to be
bringing you ideas and maybe he pays
half of the car and you go hey we're
gonna put in two grand you're gonna put
in two grand we're gonna find you a four
thousand dollar car we're gonna
negotiate it off facebook marketplace
you're gonna take it to get it inspected
and i think that will help him see this
card differently
okay okay yeah because i was just
looking at dealerships i mean
your options are going to be facebook
marketplace craigslist and autotrader
and sort by lowest price in your area
maybe even drive a few miles to go find
this car that's that's a good and at
that price point two miles that's
amazing what just cash will do
go get five thousand dollars cash bring
it to the house and say hey here's what
i got and you may even get a good deal
right i mean i know i know used car
prices are insane right now but still
there's still some some ways to
get a deal negotiate all of that but it
would be through more of it it would be
an individual not a dealer i would not
go through a dealership
the dealers aren't messing with cars
that cheap right now yeah oh yeah okay
so my take away is your suggestion if
you're in our shoes
not do the claim get a cheap car and
just
just keep that you know for a few years
and then go from there yeah and i'm
gonna still stay on that police report
i'm gonna i mean cars turn up it's crazy
and it may take a few weeks but if it's
not in the chop shop yet it may just be
sitting somewhere in someone's driveway
okay without the plates on it who knows
what they're doing but
it's amazing how these things turn up so
still
keep track of that but at the same time
go how much are we willing to put in
have him you know maybe come in with
half of that money and have him start
looking and have him make the decision
okay
all right you guys are wonderful thank
you thank you so much that's a tough
situation
that's that's insult to injury
and i'm like you know and i guess
obviously the insurance agent knows but
i'm like if it's if it's if your car is
stolen i mean i guess obviously your
insurance goes up like that's one of
those things where i'm like is it your
fault you know what i mean because the
different claims
depending on the situation are also
different i don't know
so i'm not in that world but it is
frightening to think about that someone
could just get in your car and take off
i know wild times yep wow well that puts
this hour of the ramsey show in the
books our thanks to austin kelly ben
james andrew and of course my co-host
rachel cruz and who could forget about
you america we appreciate you listening
in we'll be back with you before you
know
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
debt ramseysolutions.com screen we'd
love for you to come to nashville and
tell dave your story that's ramsey
solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host today joined
by rachel cruz and we are taking your
calls so call us triple eight eight two
five
five two two five
kicks us off in dallas texas jordan
welcome to the show
well thank you so much for taking my
call happy to take it what's going on
with you
well i'm a i'm a builder and i've got a
subdivision that i'm doing and
i've got a couple of lots one that i'm
gonna
build the dream house on but
i also
have the lot beside it that i'm thinking
about putting a stack house on something
i can pay cash for
i guess my question is should i
pay cash for the spec house which is
anywhere from 250 to 300
or should i go ahead and build the dream
house for the wife and kiddos and myself
and
you know pay the 250 or 300 down and get
a note on the on the other half of it
so what is the dream house going to cost
550 600
uh 6 650 somewhere in there yes sir and
how much cash do you have
on hand
well i've got about 800 right now but i
want to i've got to keep putting it back
into the business i build all these
homes with cash so i don't want to get
i don't want to you know have all my
money out
so you have no debt and you've got a
fully funded emergency fund outside of
that 800
yes sir yeah i've got about 35 000 in
savings good for you man you're crushing
it how old are you
i just turned 29 in january that's
amazing fantastic how much do you make a
year jordan well the past few years
probably a little bit more well it's
been pretty crazy lately but uh last
year i made a little over 400. whoa
nice that's incredible great job jordan
yes sir well how much do you need for
the business are you saying you need the
800 because that's basically fueling the
next house in the next house
well the next i try to build them four
at a time and so
i've got a couple more that are going to
sell here pretty quick and so that'll
get me ready for
either the 250 to 300 on the spec house
and then i'll be able to build the other
four as well or uh
you know
you own a house right now i'll have
enough money to do the next four and the
spec house if that's what you're asking
okay so are you living in a house right
now
well yes sir yeah we bought a
uh we ran my wife and i we got four kids
and we rented for a while and then i
bought a
mobile home that i fixed up and i was i
was a flipper before a builder and so
paid cash for it and it's about tripled
in price so
i'm going to have another probably 250
270 whenever we sell that but i don't
know if i'm going to
sell it outright or under finance and
i've got a couple owner finances now too
so well my thing is i would just sell it
take the 270 plus the money you have and
pay cash for that dream yeah
yeah i don't think it's worth hassling
with the owner financing i mean
this is going to put you in well i don't
like rentals but i like the owner
finances so i can you know have the
money coming in monthly but
you got money coming in monthly you got
400.
you got 400 with not a payment in the
world there's your cash flow
yes sir so that's why i see it i like
this plan a whole lot of just selling
your current home
and plus the cash you have on hand and
whatever it takes you pay cash for it
and with your income and the way the
housing market's going you'll you'll
have a nice stack of cash still left
over
yes sir to complete your next project so
that's my opinion rachel i mean you you
can go another way with this no i mean
that's that's what i would do jordan i
mean you guys i mean i was gonna even
say if i didn't even think about your
current place but i was even gonna be
okay for you taking out a small yeah if
you end up taking out a small mortgage
you're going to knock that thing out so
fast yeah your income right so there's
nothing wrong financially where i'm
going
to now like
i would sell yeah i would sell where you
guys are at now
put that cash together and man that's i
mean i love that's amazing i'm excited
for you
well thank you i sure sure appreciate it
yeah but either way it sounds like i'm
going with that that dream house and you
got four kids
and you guys have worked real hard yeah
so let's get out of that spot you're in
currently and
live it up man you've earned it you've
done this thing real real intentionally
with a lot of wisdom
well thank you i sure appreciate it yeah
man thanks so much for the call
aaron joins us up next in houston texas
erin welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
so um i recently had my car die its
engine just like completely gave out um
what kind of car is it
it's a 2012 hyundai sonata oh
okay yeah so it's currently sitting at
the hyundai dealership waiting to hear
if there the warranty is going to pay
for a new engine or not because
apparently this is like a factory defect
um but my husband are a little bit of
doomsday preppers and we're on baby step
two so we pause paying off debt to
stockpile just in case the warranty
won't pay for it so we have about
three 3 500 grand saved up right now um
and a new engine if the warranty doesn't
cover it would be between three to four
thousand
but now we're debating is it worth it to
replace new engine or do we just buy a
different used car because we don't have
any car payments right now
it sounds like it's worth it to just
repair the car because you're not going
to find a car for 3 500 bucks
yeah
that's kind of what we were leaning
towards but we were like i don't know is
it worth it like how much did you sell
it for comple how much could you sell it
for fixed everything
fixed um before the problem it was worth
about five grand according to kelly blue
book
well i'm gonna push to get i'm gonna
fight to get this thing covered it
sounds like this is not something you
should even be shelling money out for if
it's a factory defect
and i'm sure they're not happy to cover
it but i would fight them tooth and nail
to make sure it is covered and then i
drive that thing get out of debt and
then we can
upgrade okay yeah we definitely weren't
looking at upgrading to anything like
crazy right now we we just wanted to pay
cash for something if we had to how much
debt do you have
oh man um we have about 140 000 in debt
right now what's your income
um right now i'm finishing up school to
be a teacher so i'm just doing
photography on the side so i bring in
like 10 grand and my husband is a
medical resident and he brings in like
50 grand a year 55. yeah is this is
going to take a while it sounds like yes
yeah
well
what kind of debt is 140 student loans
it's all his med school loans yeah how
soon is he going to increase that income
uh he has two more years of residency
before it should go up significantly
okay
and you'll be a teacher soon enough
yeah i should start teaching in january
so all of we're just gonna plan to live
off of what he he makes and then
everything that i make will go to debt
well i'm going to stack cash right now
until you guys figure out what's next
for this car and then hopefully the
engine's repaired and we get back on the
road and all that money you stacked up
aside from the thousand dollar starter
emergency fund we throw at the debt
yeah that's kind of what we were
thinking but we just wanted confirmation
they're like are we thinking through
this correctly yeah you're doing great
that's what we're here for is
confirmation uh we're cheering you on
with this debt-free journey hope
everything works out with the car but
i'm a fighter rachel i get real one i
buckle up makeup i go i go to enneagram
eight make stress make them pay that's
right you go down to that dealership you
tell him how it's gonna tell him aaron
you tell him george sent you i'm the
least intimidating person in the world
that just realized
oh my goodness
well more of the show coming up folks
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five i promise i won't
fight you because i will lose
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of people would rather spend their
weekend doing yard work then talk about
insurance
except for me but seriously here's the
deal if you don't take the time to learn
about this stuff you'll always feel like
you're getting ripped off and making all
the wrong choices about your insurance
and around here we think learning about
money should be simple and yes even fun
so our new free five-day guide to
insurance called confidence in your
coverage makes learning about insurance
quick and practical and you might even
laugh out loud a time or two if i did my
job right
every day for five days i george
campbell will walk you through a new
insurance topic unpacking everything you
need to know to get the right coverage
for you and to top it off we're doing a
giveaway for the folks who sign up at
the end of the series you'll still have
the yard work but at least you'll know
your stuff when it comes to insurance so
go to ramseysolutions.com
confidence to sign up and get started
thousands and thousands of you have
already done it i appreciate that hope
you enjoy the videos hope you get the
right coverage that's what it's all
about we want you to have confidence in
every single area of your life when it
comes to insurance to protect your
assets your money as you build wealth so
go sign up
ramseysolutions.com confidence
chanterelle is up next in fort worth
texas chantrell welcome to the show
hi how are you we are so great how are
you what's going on i'm good okay so i'm
i'm uh
i'm trying to go to school to be a
physician assistant and i only have four
classes to go cool to to be able to
apply but my thing is with my finances i
have a
2016 mini cooper
my apr on it is 20.76
ouch and i own yeah i know and i owe
like 11
oh i'm a little bit
like 11 935
and change
and i'm trying to pay off um trying to
get my finances
under how can i best do that
is this all of the debt you have is just
a car loan
no sir i actually have two card cards
that were that are on my credit they
tried to um
settle with me but at that time i didn't
have the money
but i have approximately
92 000
in debt i i went to south university in
in savannah so that's where that debt
came from and others are
on my um debt on my uh credit report are
more like um
like bills and stuff and i'm just trying
to find a way
while taking care of those bills and
going to school at the same time so
what's the total amount of debt that you
owe between everything
a hundred and ten thousand
okay yeah there we go what's your income
i
am a pharmacy tech so i make uh 22
dollars an hour right now okay
and how how many hours do you work
what will your take home be this year do
you know have you calculated it
yeah i think it'd be at 45 000 but like
my paycheck is like maybe it's 14
1500 give or take a couple of dollars
and you still have four classes left is
that what you said yes and um and what
happens with that is the four classes
that i have to take i'm paying for those
out of pocket by cash good so
once i once i'm done with that then i
can apply to a pa program the one like
in dallas or in fort worth and how will
you pay for the pa program
i'm thinking about um getting a grad a
graduate loan that's why i'm trying to
take care of some of the stuff on my
credit because
i've i've been going to school since i
since i'm 24 i'm now 37 and everything
i've done has been has been on my own
dime whether it's been by
by getting a loan or paying for it by
cash well it sounds like the loans have
been setting you back i mean 13 years
and we're sitting here with a hundred
and ten thousand dollars in student and
in debt
yes for my bachelor's degree yes
well i don't want i want to stop the
bleeding here so i want you to stop
going into debt and if that means we
take a pause on pa school to clean this
up i'm okay with that because what i
don't want is you leave pa school and
now you've got 250 000 in debt and you
can't breathe
no i can't are you able to pay all of
your bills right now
bad i am yes yes
on all your current bills
um i mean i got i got my car note that's
coming up
what is it what's the car worth
the car
it's got 87 000 miles on it so
it may be maybe 10
10 12 000
are you guessing are you really sure
okay yeah i
in this case i might sell this car i
mean you got 21 interest on this thing
and if you can get out from under it and
do you have any money saved right now do
you have any money in the bank
no that's the thing i don't it's like i
like i helped my sister and who's
epileptic and her two children are um
that are like that have meant that have
mental
and capability so uh some i know some of
my money that i give to her it does go
has been going to my sister
to help her but um
that that's the thing i really
i really want to you know go to school
but at the same time it's like yeah my
money is just not allowing me so yeah
totally so central i i you have so many
things going for you number one you're
you're a hard worker
uh number two you're extremely generous
um taking care of the people in your
life that you love that need that help
um but my but what i'm fearful for you
is that you're continuing to do the same
things over and over again right and and
it's getting you in this hole where
you're like oh i can't get out and i
don't know what to do
which means we're gonna have to stop
doing things that you were doing in
order to get
a solid financial foundation under you
to give you some breathing room and some
peace
so that the things that you want to do
like helping people and go to school and
advance your career all that so that
that can be done in a way that's going
to bless you and bless people versus
continuing to harm you and digging you
deeper in this financial hole
um and so there's kind of a that mental
shift that you have to make for yourself
to say okay
what what can i do now so i'm with
george there's um
you know i would love for you to get rid
of this car asap so really my first goal
you have the money you said to
get through school and that's not money
saved is that like working as you go
kind of thing yes yes ma'am because the
school i go to go to i pay it by on
payment plans and so okay right matter
of fact i work as a medical scribe at a
local at a local hospital down here so
good okay
and when will you be when will you be
done with school
before i can really push it i can be
done
because the classes are very hard to get
into i could be done by the end of this
year okay so by december you would be
done okay so if i were you um
between now and december my goal is to
get out of school debt-free cash flow
like your plan was
my goal is to
take on an extra job um where i can to
get that income up
to be able to save up some cash get rid
of this car
sell the car
get a car that's you know
four thousand dollars we were just
talking to another caller about this uh
in the last segment
um and to be able to replace you know to
be able to have a vehicle
um get rid of the car and then and then
start looking at paying off
these student loans and i
you're gonna hate this advice but i
really would i would work to
be debt free um and pay off this 92
and then with that same work ethic with
that same intensity continuing to work
those hours have a lot of cash flow
coming in and work your way through the
school you want to go to next um
and so again my ho what i want for you
is to be able to say okay
i obviously have you know my hope would
obviously be no debt and you have that
that foundation under you that is steady
because it feels a little shaky right
now but it's going to take some time and
it's going to take a lot of hard work
and how much money is is going to your
sister
in the past
year
i can say between
who you're you guys um between
500 to 2000 plus
okay
okay over the year
over the years okay okay that's good
i mean
again that's a that's a value decision
for you to make um it's not a huge chunk
of this so if that's something that you
want to continue to do
um that's an option or if you want to
pause everything for for a little bit
and get yourself in a position where
you're going to be able to be even more
generous when you get out of debt yeah
i know it's hard to hear chanterelle
because it sounds like we're telling you
to go backwards but really we're saying
slow down so that you can speed up later
so you're not looking at the same spot
you're in 13 more years from now
hey hold on the line austin's going to
pick up we're going to give you a free
membership of financial peace university
for a year and comes with every dollar
plus a budgeting app once you get you
want to get yourself on a budget as well
but go through that class on us this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined by rachel cruz
today
zach joins us up next in jackson wyoming
zach welcome to the show
hey george hey i was just talking to you
on instagram just yes a couple hours ago
you had a great question i said zach
call into the show and you did it i'm
proud of you man
yeah thanks man i had the cars and come
out at work but i appreciate the
opportunity so here's the basic
situation george i kind of talked to you
a little bit monday about my financial
situation um you know i'm in school and
i've been dating this girl for about
eight months and uh i guess i'm just
looking for
um some direction i don't know if i
should wait
like i have three years left to school
so i don't know if i should wait till
after three years before i ask her to
marry me or if i should you know kind of
see how things are going but is it okay
to do it while in school like i just i
want to make sure it makes sense
financially because i want to set myself
up for success
what as well as her i don't want to
bring her on to you know uh
an unstable financial relationship how
old are you zach
i'm 19. 19. and you have three years of
school is she in school
oh she will be this fall and she will
have three years as well
okay
um is she 18
no no she's 19. she's 19 i'll be 20 this
month and she'll be 20 um in september
oh okay sorry i was thinking she had
like just graduated um
high school so there's two parts here uh
can you get married while in college is
it bad no rachel did it
i did so there's proof i had a semester
left and uh you're doing fine rachel you
and winston running great how many years
now
we're going on 12 or no we're going on
13. there we go i know i had a semester
left but i will say zach my semester was
full of my electives so i had so much
she told me she took a walking class i
did walking social dance tennis and
badminton this is at ut yeah and i was a
respectable institution it was all my
electives so y'all are gonna have like
intent so you're gonna have
school how are you going to support
if you go forward zach let's say you do
get married uh what are you gonna be
doing for a job
so i'm right now majoring in electrical
engineering and minoring in mathematics
i have some internships lined out i'm
here pretty soon working hopefully at a
national laboratory i have several
people tied into that that have told me
they're going to help me
and uh i believe from what i've seen
online and heard from some friends who
have family members working there you
know it could be anywhere from 75 to 115
000 a year
um wow
or once you graduate well this this
would be once i graduated
would just be to get my leg in the door
sure um okay so i know i could take care
of it i just i don't want to
i'm cash flowing my way through school i
have well i have a bunch of scholarships
like i think i have like 76 000 in
scholarships right now
um and she's got a bunch of scholarships
as well that she's i don't even know if
she has to pay for anything while she's
in school uh anyway so like i i know i
think i can make it all work out uh i
just
yeah i don't know
i'm not as worried about it on paper i
just think you know let's wait till
obviously emotionally relationally ready
the financial part i mean you guys both
seem like you're pretty nerdy about this
stuff so i think you can figure out the
money yeah because marriage i mean your
wedding's going to cost something but
you guys living together obviously
you're going to have to like
you know be able to eat and keep the
lights on and all of that there's no
rush and maybe you know maybe senior
year you guys are still together it's
serious you've been together a few years
pop the question senior year and maybe
after graduation we have the wedding
would that feel good i don't know i
don't even put that i don't know you
could get married before graduation yeah
i'm fine with that yeah and i think it's
more like you get married when you guys
are ready to get married financially
you're going to be fine school's going
to take care of yeah are you are you
adding a level of
interesting dynamics by getting married
in school while taking classes and
having to work i mean you're doing a
double load it's kind of what that is
because you're gonna have to work and go
to school
all that um so sure there'll be a little
bit of of stress there but people do it
all the time so i think y'all totally
can but it would it would be more my
question of more of a dr john jaloni
relational
angle i would be more worried just
making sure that you guys
well at night are you ready to get
married and that this is it young love
you know you're just like i could do
that i want to pop the question to and i
get that but in college it's like you're
there's so much life to explore you're
figuring out yourself i feel like in
college you don't really know what the
future holds what your values are you're
developing all those things but you guys
sound like you have good heads on your
shoulders there's no rash decisions
being made so no there's no right or
wrong as far as should we get married
while in college just do it when you're
ready i'm not as worried about the money
part because you guys are both super
sharp
right well i appreciate that i just you
know i try to analyze everything as best
i can because i i hate when i make
mistakes and i know you know nobody's
perfect but
um spoken like a true engineer
right
yeah no mistakes but anyway i i just
don't want to bring
you know i don't want to start off wrong
but i i understand what you're saying
and i know i'm in no hurry i don't want
to put emotion in front of logic i just
i'm kind of in between you know what i
mean yeah yeah i think you'd be totally
fine zach you're taking
the right level of wisdom towards this
yeah you know and it's a serious
decision uh so don't rush into anything
but i think once you once you both have
you know you've had some more serious
conversations you're getting closer
towards graduation let's let's figure
that out and if we decide yeah now's the
time we can make this work it's no
problem yep absolutely thank you so much
for the question man appreciate that
from instagram there you go i know nice
shout out if you want to follow us uh
we've been doing some fun instagram
reels together yes we have so
chick-fil-a hacks blew up we were on the
unofficial chick-fil-a podcast i know
we've got we are reaching out to us so
you can check out our knowledge
at rachel cruz on instagram c r
c-r-u-z-e
a lot of people forget to eat that's
true and uh george george campbell with
a k george
k-a-m-e-l you can find us on instagram
we'd love to connect
all right our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why they are the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from leslie in
wisconsin my 14 year old son has had a
successful lawn mowing business for
three years and has approximately 25
accounts during the summer months he
also works construction for with his dad
when the time allows and will take over
the company someday
wow it's all that's a lot to start
wearing he's going on a 14 year old
um
he is very skilled for only being 14. he
can roof pour concrete frame he has a
healthy savings account about 17. i'm
sorry 7
he has already paid cash for his own
vehicle and paid cash for all of his
mowing equipments
what should he be doing to invest with
all the cash he's making
this kid is a unicorn
at 14 years old it's a proud mom
question did you hear all that that is
yeah there's a flex
but she is well well deserved leslie you
raised a great kid so leslie honestly at
this point i would i would have him keep
saving so
you know when you're 14
college is going to be here in what four
years if he decides to do that he's not
he's going to skip that he's already
crushing it he might skip it um
but i i you know the tr there's no rush
to invest and yes we all know compound
interest we know the earlier start the
better off you're going to be we know
all of that but also when you're 14 that
that trend that world between 14 and 21
whether it's college or not what yeah
there could be i mean who knows and i
wouldn't even put i don't this this is
not even what leslie asked i don't even
know if she's listening but i also want
to make sure that he was not like being
pinned into this yeah he's 14. position
take over his company at 14 i'm like oh
gosh and how is he he's he paid cash for
a vehicle how is he driving at 14 is it
just sitting in the garage until he's
right that's that's the midwest for you
if you were raised in the country i'm a
city slicker from boston oh you those
kids they drive 16 and a half to get our
permit rachel no yes no
that's the america i lived in stop it
100 maybe it was maybe it was 15 and a
half
maybe 16 and a half was licensed but at
a half where i've never even heard of
that knows where the half comes from i
don't know that might have been a camel
family oh okay i don't know if i trust
so as far as investing goes if you
wanted to split some things and go all
right we're going to take some of this
income we're going to give some save
some spend some if you want to invest
you could open a custodial roth ira uh
because he's not he can only open one on
his own when he's 18. so you guys would
have control but he could be investing
right now but i would not be shoveling
all of his money into investments let
him be a kid and it's 7 500 bucks which
is amazing but we're not talking about
like half a million dollars right junior
means so like he's 14 so yeah he needs
to pump the brakes a little bit i think
let him enjoy some of that money give
some of it like you said save some of if
he does want to invest yeah there's
options but it's not do you want to put
a few hundred bucks in the roth ira
every month i mean he'll be a
millionaire regardless i think he's
gonna be just fine he's gonna do great
great job leslie wow
are the auntie's up rachel what are your
kids doing are they driving yet
we'll get there
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
exodus 33 14. the lord replied i will
personally go with you and i will give
you rest
john steinbeck said it is a common
experience that a problem difficult at
night is resolved in the morning after
the committee of sleep has worked on it
i like that no
that's very rachel cruz you know just
sleep on it's amazing what sleep can do
especially when james our producers in a
crabby mood i just say james go take a
nap go nap james he always feels better
when he wakes up
trey joins us up next in houston texas
trey welcome to the show
uh thank you guys for taking my call
what's going on yeah hanging out man
what's going on with you
uh nothing much i have um so my
situation um i haven't paid my taxes in
about four years
um when i was uh i think i was about 20
started this job at a warehouse
and um we get paid uh
without the taxes being taken out so we
get a 1099 form at the end of the year
and i kind of just have been putting it
off you know and just not worried about
it i wasn't making that much money so i
i didn't think that taxes would you know
be that much
um but now um i i'm going to be making
about about 40 000 um and i kind of just
want to know what's the
best action to take about getting all
this under control
what's the total tax debt
um i actually i haven't i haven't i
didn't file or anything for those years
so i mean i just have my my income
amount i don't even i don't have any
idea what the what the back taxes are
yes sir so has the irs contacted you
no they haven't
wow well my first step is to look in the
mirror and go what the heck is going on
with all this and what do i owe because
it's not going to go away right they're
not going to just go well
just let that one slip by trey got away
so that's my first thing is i'm going to
be proactive and contact them and go hey
here's the situation i haven't paid i
want to pay what is the amount that i
owe
all right what's your what's your other
debt
um so i have about 600 in credit cards
um
and i have a repossession in collections
from
like 2014 that's about it
what's that amount
uh that amount i think was last time i
looked at it on my experience it was
about 14 000 was the balance i think
okay and is that all of your debts you
six hundred income really gold it's a
really old yeah yeah six hundred and
forty i have two credit cards the 300 of
these okay
do you still have the credit cards
yes i do okay how much money do you have
in the bank
uh about 10 grand
okay
well let's clean up those credit cards
today well the ir i was going to say the
irs he didn't know how much it is i know
but i would i would i
don't we could disagree on this george
i'm not sure but listen i wouldn't we
could i just don't know how long it's
going to take to get those numbers i
know but i would be i would be saving as
much as possible try because the irs
stuff
that was kind of my plan i knew i was
going to have to pay so my plan this
whole time was kind of just stack up as
much money as i can yeah you can do them
finally do that yeah and you can just go
online and do a rough calculation and
look at your tax bracket look at what
you made pull your pay stubs from the
last four years just to get a rough
estimate of okay here's kind of what
here's what it's going to look like
um and again but i would contact yeah
get on a payment plan and pay it off as
soon as possible because the irs stuff
is something that's like the first debt
that you do not want to mess around with
and like i said it's just a little
not scared i'm not scared about it it's
just i know i know it's looming yeah
yeah i'm getting there
i mean
totally well i'm really proud of you
trey for like i mean really this is like
being in a zone right you're looking at
yourself you're like okay i'm an adult i
got to do adult things i got to pay
taxes i got to stay on but like i got to
do this stuff i have a kid as well so
okay yeah yeah so you really want to
yeah you're starting to turn stuff
around which is awesome so
um if i were you i'd cut up your credit
cards i would i would get on a really
tight budget tray and because you're
going to be making great income you said
40 000 i would see
you know if you if there's extra work
you can pick up and then get yeah get
everything in writing from the irs of
what you owe and then that needs to be
your first priority is to pay all that
off and then you're going to be working
so much and making so much that by the
time it gets down when you're done with
the irs
debt that 600 credit card bill continue
to make minimum payments yeah um but
that'll be wiped off real fast because
of how much you're going to be working
um but it really is i wanted to just
throw the whole though 600 at it and
just wipe it out completely stock and
stop worrying about it
right now you could i mean you could i'm
i'm backing out now i agree with you
rachel that irs debt we do put at the
top of the debt snowball trade which is
when we say list them out from smallest
to largest but irs debt always goes to
the top but today if i had to make one
decision today with the information we
have like all right well knock it write
a check maybe it'll make you it'll give
you that progress that little boost of
like i can do this yeah i got rid of one
we can get rid of two if we get rid of
two we get rid of five so it's not it's
just not that big of a number if it was
five grand i'd go let's hold off on the
credit cards let's focus on there's that
but a1 is figuring that out that's been
crazy
and i'd i'd be working 60 80 80 hours a
week i know you got the kid so that
could change things but i'm gonna be
busting it to try to get that income as
high as i can to clean this debt up as
fast as i can because trey what's so
encouraging to me though is hearing you
talk where i'm like you know you're 27.
um up until this point it's like you
know you've probably been working but
you know you had a re you know you had a
repo you have some credit card debt you
kind of just been like going through
life and now it just feels like this
wake-up call happened inside of you
where you're like i want to do this
because here's what's crazy trey with
the numbers that we're running once you
are out of debt you clean up the
repossession clean up the irs debt right
which is going to take a little bit this
is not going to happen overnight this
will take this may take two or three
years
but at your age
say you just started at 30 years old
what your life could look like from that
point forward financially could you
could literally retire a millionaire
because you have so much time on your
side and you're able to start investing
you're gonna have cash in the bank for
an emergency fund you're gonna be saving
for your kids college like there's
things you know in your mind
too oh that's awesome that's awesome are
you putting money into it right now
um just sixty dollars a week okay let's
cut that out because right now we're
going to be focused on this debt we're
going to get back to investors pause it
for now and are you so okay is there any
other uh source of income you could get
right now to help clean up this debt
are you already maxed out
um
i'm sure there's some things i could
pick up to get some extra income in okay
maybe some handy jobs
yeah i want you to point all of those
dollars towards the debt obviously we
need to cover the four walls put food on
the table cover your bills but outside
of that it's not time to have fun we're
not eating out we're going to get game
on getting rid of the irs debt cleaning
this mess up and never looking back
right
and we're going to send you
financial peace university that's nine
video lessons that it's gonna it's gonna
encourage you it's gonna give you a lot
of education and give you that direct
plan of what you need to do and it will
also give you every dollar premium our
budgeting tool
so that you can make a plan for all this
money it's all included at ramsey plus
so hang on the line austin's going to
pick up and we'll get make sure you get
that doing great trey
that's a lot rachel people are going
through some things oh absolutely i mean
it's tough it really is but
you know we hear every show when we have
debt-free screams which we've had to
this show and
you know sometimes every hour on the
show
and there's this consistency of people
that when they decide to change their
life
they're the secret sauce that's what we
say around here like when they decide
i can do this no one else is going to
come help him fix my life no one's going
to come rescue me i have to get up and
decide what decisions am i going to make
day in and day out that is going to
change the way i handle my money and the
progress that i'm going to make it's up
to me it's up to me and that's that's
that factor that's a hard decision and
that's where i feel like i heard trey
say like that's what i was hearing right
i just heard him
you know like i don't know what it was
this may not even be a story but it's
like the light bulb went off and he's
like
i i got to do this i got i got i got to
figure all this out
and it's me right and we're the answer
you're the answer out there and and yes
inflation is terrible we're on the brink
of a recession like every this world
it's crazy it's like the sky is falling
but
it's amazing though when you don't have
debt
and you pay it off you don't have a car
loan
your credit card bills aren't coming in
every month you have no debt you have
money in the bank saved it's a different
position and that is what we talk about
on the show all the time but it is it's
it's the truth that it's the money
principles that work in good times and
in bad times yes and even people who
think we're crazy are not going maybe
that advice isn't so crazy maybe we
should get out of debt and have some
money in the bank yeah that could help
so you can do this stuff america you
just gotta decide make a decision look
in the mirror and go that guy in the
mirror that woman in the mirror they're
the problem and they're the solution and
that is where freedom starts we believe
in you that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books our thanks to austin
kelly james ben andrew rachel and you
america thanks for listening in until
next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you